[Music]
one of the things that will get in your
way of learning poi is being afraid of
the point so I see this a lot I teach
poi a lot and often when I see people
are going to learn a new move and they
keep flinching because the poi might hit
them so this is and this is of course
this happens I mean we millions of years
of evolution taught us that if
something's flying towards our head
pipbuck that's why we're here because we
got good at ducking and to some extent
so don't hold that against yourself you
know in fact be grateful that our
ancestors learned to duck my philosophy
in my approach to poi is a use soft POI
something really soft that's not going
to hurt you I think if you want to learn
to get over that flinching and you want
to you know so that you can just relax
and learn new things without your body
always trying to you know get out of the
way take your soft boy and just hit
yourself a lot like you know maybe
there's a couple places you don't
undersell but get you set in fact you
know this is all these poems that are
all based around the poi hitting
yourself right so it's actually super
fun way to play in the long run and the
sooner you get used to it the sooner
you'll stop being so afraid of the play
oh yeah it's another thing if you learn
the spin gently you'll be much less
afraid of your play so you know when
you're warming up and playing just you
know remind yourself that it's just soft
poi and if you spin gently it's not
gonna hurt and the sooner you get used
to this the sooner you can learn
something like crossing backwards or
doing a backward weave and you won't be
trying to duck because if you're
flinching you won't notice what's
happening if you're just watching no it
didn't quite make it to the other side
it almost made it to the other side good
they made it to the other side and then
you'll progress much quicker so even
though it sounds funny hit yourself in
the head with the poi a lot
and they'll be thankful for it
[Music]